sujet passionnant qui fait couler
beaucoup d'encre c'est l'arrivée d'une
nouvelle
iPad de 10e génération qui était dans
cette boîte là l'iPad de 10e génération
il a plein de nouveautés ils changent
vraiment par rapport à l'iPad de 9e
génération il vient un peu se
repositionner dans la gamme et ça
intéressant vous voyez il y a des
couleurs qui pètent un peu tous les
côtés je vais tout vous expliquer ce qui
va ce qui ne va pas les questions qu'on
va tout regarder et d'ici quelques jours
donc pensez déjà à venir vous abonner on
se parle de celui-là ça c'est le nouvel
iPad pro
iPad pro qui va être très très bon avec
la nouvelle puce m2 donc on va se parler
de l'iPad pro on va se parler du Magic
keyboard qui est là dedans on va se
parler de l'Apple pencil de deuxième
génération ça c'est uniquement pour le
nouvel iPad pro aujourd'hui on se
concentre sur l'iPad de dixième
génération on a ici le Magic key
banfolio qui est intéressant et on a ici
un Apple pencil de première génération
ok alors attends attends il y a plein de
choses à venir voir c'est un peu le
bordel ici là vous voyez sur mon bureau
parce que j'ai des accessoires de tous
les côtés j'ai j'ai un bloc de charge
bref il y a plein de choses à venir
raconter on va commencer par le
commencement le commencement c'est sa
taille pas de là attendez je vais virer
les accessoires je vais vous enlever un
peu tout ça essayez de faire place net
cet iPad là il est nouveau il vient
succéder à l'iPad de 9e génération qu'on
a connu l'année dernière qui lui-même
succédé à l'iPad de 8e génération qui
lui-même vous avez compris l'histoire il
y a vraiment un renouveau c'est vraiment
ce que veut faire Apple ici on dit ok on
va changer un peu l'histoire on va venir
renouveler le look donc ça taille pas de
dixième génération marque un vrai
changement je pense que c'est peut-être
le fait d'avoir la dixième génération
par rapport à la 9e génération déjà le
gros changement va venir se faire
vraiment je dis au niveau de
l'esthétique vous n'avez plus le gros
bouton touch ID qu'on retrouvait avant
donc on a un nouveau design qui nous
rappelle davantage l'iPad air donc ça
c'est cool on arrive dans autre chose
vous avez le petit bouton c'est touch
Idy alors on l'avait avec l'iPad air
vous prenez vous posez votre doigt vous
appuyez et vous déverrouillez très
facilement ça c'est cool mais ça le fait
également dans l'autre sens donc ce qui
vous demande de faire c'est venir ce
qu'il y a un autre doigt donc vous
prenez vous appuyez vous posez votre
doigt vous déverrouillez donc que vous
l'ayez en mode portrait ou en mode
paysage vous allez déverrouiller très
facilement ça on l'avait sur l'iPad air
et un sur l'iPad air donc c'est cool de
l'avoir réussi sur un iPad d'entrée de
gamme c'est plus dur à dire aujourd'hui
mais c'est un petit peu ça l'idée donc
ça c'est le premier point qui est
intéressant le deuxième point c'est
d'être venu apporter des couleurs un peu
plus flashy jusqu'à l'iPad neuf vous
aviez uniquement le gris sidéral et la
couleur argent là ils sont dit on va
mettre de la couleur on veut je pense
d'un côté un peu plus tonique et que ça
attire peut-être un peu plus de monde
alors moi j'ai un joli petit jeune là
mais il existe également en rose en bleu
et en couleur argent entre nouveautés au
niveau de cet iPad c'est l'écran on a
une diagonale d'écran qui est plus
grande on passe de 10,2 pouces en l'iPad
9 à 10,9 pouces c'est pas grand chose
mais c'est toujours ça qui est pris ça
c'est bien la résolution va augmenter
aussi un petit peu 2360 par 1640 pixels
luminosité maximale de 500 litres ok on
s'en fout un peu c'est bien on a le
troutone donc un écran qui est
maîtrisait une belle dalle qui
fonctionne bien comme c'est le faire
Apple une dalle qui est quand même assez
réfléchissante donc vous voyez si vous
avez de la lumière par derrière
attention ça va venir se voir et
réfléchir sur votre iPad au-delà de ça
la dalle est bien de bonne qualité ça
fonctionne bien pas de souci là-dessus
autre truc qui est intéressant sont les
haut-parleurs alors on avait déjà allé
haut-parleur avant mais ce que nous dit
Apple ici c'est des hauts par leur
stéréos en mode paysage c'est à dire
comme ça vous voyez l'expérience est
bonne il y a du son ça marche bien à
droite à gauche pas de souci ici une
fois de plus c'est bien maîtrisé de la
part d'Apple donc pas de mauvaise
surprise on a un petit top Greg aussi on
avait du Bluetooth 4.2 on passe au
Bluetooth 5.2 ça c'est cool et puis une
des mises à jour qui va être le plus
intéressant c'est la performance on
passe sur la puce a qui a 14 Bionic ne
permet d'avoir un peu plus de
performance fatalement pour faire plus
de choses ici donc ça c'est cool si tu
as pas des disponible en 74 gigas de
stockage et en 256 autre point qui est
bien il faut venir le souligner vous
avez votre bloc de charge qui est inclut
ici donc ça c'est bien vous le recharger
alors rapidement attention on a des plus
grosses batteries donc ça ira moins vite
qu'un smartphone mais c'est quand même
assez rapide ça c'est bien votre câble
qui est inclus pour venir le recharger
aussi donc ça ça va bien donc vous avez
votre bloc qui est à l'intérieur et
c'est cool mais la grosse différence par
rapport à l'année dernière c'est quoi
c'est que vous avez l'arrivée de l'USB C
ici alors je sais pas si vous avez suivi
l'actualité mais c'est une directive
européenne je crois que c'est à partir
de 2024 si je dis pas de bêtises il ne
pourra y avoir que de l'usb-c en Europe
plus de Lightning plus de port autre que
de l'USB dans l'idée de venir harmoniser
et dans une question écologique donc ici
Apple a pris déjà allé devant en
enlevant son Lightning alors ça c'est
vachement cool mais ça pose aussi
quelques problèmes puisque effectivement
donc déjà on met du câble ici en usb-c
mais ça se branche ça va bien mais je
dirais que le truc qui est un peu
différent c'est que Apple nous mettait
déjà sur l'iPad 9 un Apple pencil de
première génération donc ils ont
conservé l'Apple pencil de première
génération ce qui me paraît pas
déconnant ici parce que c'est dans la
gamme ça vient vraiment différencier ce
produit du reste de la gamme ok sauf que
je vous mets dans le mille l'Apple
pencil de première génération il s'en
charge comment il s'en charge par ici
mais il s'en charge surtout uniquement
en Lightning alors Apple est pas venu
créer un port usb-c au dos pour bien le
recharger non ils ont fait un truc qui
savent faire c'est à dire ils ont créé
un adaptateur alors ça aurait pu
paraître plus simple de se dire ok Apple
pourrait nous mettre directement ici un
Apple pencil de deuxième génération
parce qu'il y a deux avantages par
rapport à la première génération la
première c'est de venir se recharger
sans fil donc vous le prenez vous le
posez sur votre iPad air pas ici ou sur
l'iPad air et ça vient se recharger et
puis le deuxième point forcément pour
bien se recharger c'est qu'il est magnét
non ici Apple a gardé son Apple pencil
de première génération parce qu'il faut
de plus ils veulent le prolonger dans le
temps et ils veulent différencier les
gammes ce que je comprends une fois de
plus mais le problème c'est comme on est
maintenant ici sur de l'usb-c et bien on
vient faire un peu de l'abricole alors
je vous montre le système de bricole
vous venez effectivement retirer ici le
petit capuchon pour venir faire
apparaître le Lightning ils vont dans un
adaptateur vous allez payer 10 €
Lightning usb-c donc vous venez le
brancher hop là directement là ensuite
vous prenez votre câble que vous enlevez
là et vous venez le brancher directement
ici et là vous rechargez l'histoire
alors le problème c'est que ça vous fait
un espèce de système de bouzin qu'il
faut tout le temps avoir avec soi il
faut avoir son câble en général on l'a
parce qu'on veut venir se recharger il
faut avoir l'adaptateur il ne faut pas
perdre adaptateur et lorsque vous avez
fait ça et bien il faut pas perdre ici
son petit bouchon bon ça on avait
l'habitude avant ça pose pas trop de
problèmes alors vous allez voir que ce
système il est pas forcément extrêmement
évident même si ça va on y arrive on le
met dans un petit sac une petite sacoche
on referme tout va bien mais vous allez
voir qu'en termes de tarifs il y a des
choses un petit peu surprenantes on va
regarder ça dans quelques instants on
continue bon alors toute l'expérience
logiciel je vous apprends rien ici on
est sur iPad au S16 il est livré
directement avec l'expérience est très
bonne donc là-dessus ça fonctionne et
pas de mauvaise surprise l'autonomie bon
ça dépendrait pas plus de vous de vos
usages ici on a à peu près une journée
personnellement quand j'utilise ici mon
iPad je l'utilise de façon fractionnée
sous un produit divertissement donc je
le garde longtemps et comme c'est du
divertissement et que je suis à la
maison je le branche je le recharge
lorsque je l'utilise pas et je n'ai
absolument aucun problème donc ça c'est
très très pratique mais il y a une autre
nouveauté que je trouve extrêmement
intéressante regardez je vous montre
c'est dans la partie appareil photo
puisque ils vous ont mis à l'avant une
caméra de selfie qui est située juste
ici en haut alors qu'avant elle était
sur le côté donc on avait un cadre qui
était pas terrible et là on a un très
bon cadre donc ça c'est vachement bien
en plus de ça cette caméra de selfie
elle est intéressante parce qu'elle est
ultra grand angle vous montez jusqu'à
122 degrés donc vous voyez franchement
ça c'est vachement bien que si vous
voulez faire de la visio à plusieurs
vous pouvez le faire oh ton truc est
très bien ici dans l'iPad vous avez le
cadre centré alors le cadre centré ça
permet quoi ça permet de vous voir et de
venir vous suivre voyez en fait comme
vous avez une caméra ultra grand angle
et bien c'est toujours votre caméra de
temps en temps qui va venir suivre vos
mouvements directement à plat je passe
par ici elle me retrouve par ici et il y
a un truc qui est très sympa donc ça
c'est plutôt rigolo et ça marche bien
donc l'idée qui est vraiment la plus
intéressante ici c'est le fait d'avoir
positionné votre caméra au centre juste
là parce que Apple c'est très bien que
on veut utiliser son iPad pour des visio
et même un iPad 10 qui n'est pas
forcément d'iPad pro ni un iPad air
restaura suffisamment performant pour
faire de la vision avec de la famille ou
même de la visio professionnelle donc ça
c'est chouette alors pour ça on a un
petit accessoire c'est le Magic qui
board folio et je vous en parle dans
quelques instants à l'arrière se
trouvait qu'une caméra de 10 mégapixels
versus 8 mégapixels avant et on peut
venir faire ici de la vidéo 4K jusqu'à
60 images par seconde pour autant
va-t-on venir faire ici de la vidéo en
4k avec sa tablette je n'en suis
absolument pas convaincu mais si vous le
voulez vous pouvez autre évolution
intéressante vous avez du wifi 6 versus
du wifi 5 avant deux micros pour la
réduction de bruit pour vos appels
téléphoniques ça veut dire supprimer un
peu le bruit ambiant ok why not elle
existe en modèle wifi mais également en
modèle wifi plus cellular ça vous permet
de venir vous connecter en 5G très
facilement le truc intéressant avec ça
c'est que vous avez soit une nano SIM
vous pouvez mettre directement en
physique dedans soit une estime à vous
de voir moi il y a un truc ici qui me
fait un peu râler et je vous dis tout de
suite c'est que Apple a supprimé la
prise jack j'adorais l'idée d'avoir une
prise directe sur mon
iPad le plus accessible et bien
aujourd'hui il y en a plus vous voyez
avant elle était juste en haut elle a
disparu ça c'est vraiment le truc qui me
fait un peu de peine parce que alors je
sais hein bien évidemment on a tous des
casques Bluetooth mais certaines
personnes n'en ont pas ils vont toujours
un casque avec une prise jack et se
faisait plaisir sur un iPad en venant
brancher son casque en prise directe
aujourd'hui c'était plus possible donc
il faudra uniquement avoir des écouteurs
Bluetooth bon après il me direz-vous il
y a une évolution aussi avec de
Bluetooth 5.2 bon voilà ça peut se
comprendre alors je vous le disais il y
a un accessoire qui est intéressant
c'est que vous allez retrouver hop là ce
Magic qui board follow alors le Magic
keyboardfolio ont décale tout ça il est
en deux parties première partie vous
allez reposer votre tablette directement
là il va venir se monter donc on peut
venir l'utiliser tout seul en mode
chevalet ça vient s'ouvrir là donc vous
pouvez me poser comme ça pour vous
regarder un film une série là on le
descend mais pas trop trop aboyer là je
suis un peu au maximum je peux pas
descendre plus bas vous voyez c'est un
angle comme ça
par inclus et après ça vous permet de
venir le transporter ça vous fait une
petite protection comme ça et ça c'est
assez marrant alors maintenant je
constate un peu de tarif parce que c'est
vraiment le nerf de la guerre et ce qui
est intéressant ici et c'est ça qui est
un peu un peu fou fou alors regardez
votre iPad de base il coûte 589 €, ça
c'est la base en 64 Go de stockage et la
version 256 on est à 789 € autant vous
dire que là quand même en terme de tarif
c'est tout de suite beaucoup plus haut
et là on est uniquement en version Wi-Fi
parce que si vous le voulez en wifi plus
cellulaire avec une carte 5G parce qu'on
a ici de la 5G versus de la 4G avant ça
j'ai oublié de vous lire c'est
intéressant également et bien c'est plus
le même tarif on commence à 789 euros
ici en version toujours en 64 Go et on
monte à 989 euros quasiment 1000 euros
sur l'iPad de base le plus haut le plus
gros et ça c'est sans l'appel pencil
avant l'Apple pencil il coûtait 99 €.
c'était son tarif de base aujourd'hui
vous pouvez venir le trouver pour du
parapluie avec accessoire là cet
accessoire là qui coûte 10 euros et bien
aujourd'hui vous avez un package où il
vous le sorte à 119 euros ça veut dire
que 99 + 10 ça fait combien ça fait 109
mais chez Apple 99 + 10 ça fait 119
voilà donc le package il est un peu plus
cher ça des petits trucs où ça fait
râler parce qu'en fait un produit que
vous auriez acheté un an 99 vous allez
payer aujourd'hui 119 €, il y a
l'inflation j'en doute pas hein mais si
vous regardez l'iPad 9 l'iPad 9 quand il
est sorti il coûtait 389 euros ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui on a quand même pris
200 € de plus par rapport aux produits
qui est sorti l'année dernière alors il
y a une évolution le design n'est pas le
même touch Heidi est déplacé enfin bref
je vous expliquais ça et l'iPad 9 si
vous voulez l'acheter aujourd'hui il est
toujours dispo catalogue d'Apple sauf
que maintenant il ne coûte plus 389
euros le prix auquel il est sorti il
coûte maintenant 439 euros et ça c'est
très bizarre parce que peut-être que
c'est dû à l'inflation j'en sais rien
mais c'est très rare de voir un produit
qui un an après sa sortie coûte 50 euros
de plus que le moment où il est sorti le
général les produits coûtent moins cher
là il coûte plus cher et je trouve ça
dingue donc bon alors après une fois de
plus est-ce que c'est l'inflation est-ce
est-ce que je peux vous recommander cet
iPad de dixième génération oui parce
qu'il y a plein de très jolies
évolutions maintenant le tarif il fait
quand même mal pour un iPad de 10e
génération soyons clair ouais je garde
par rapport à ce qu'on a connu vous
voyez 389 € l'année dernière pour la
même gamme vous m'auriez dit allez il
est à 429 € 450 j'aurais dit je
comprends c'est cher mais c'est beau et
ça brille en jaune donc voilà à vous de
me dire ce que vous en pensez en bas
dans les commentaires est-ce que vous
pourriez tenter ou alors pas qu'est-ce
que vous pensez du fait garder l'Apple
pencil de première génération ce qui me
paraît pas moi déconnant une fois de
plus attention il faut vraiment venir
séparer les gammes je comprends l'idée
de le garder comme ça je comprends de
pas mettre de support magnétique parce
que ça coûterait plus cher pour passer
sur un appel petit de 2e génération
alors dernier truc que j'ai oublié de
vous dire c'est le tarif de Magic
keyboard folio il coûte 299 euros après
il existe un smartphone U à 99 euros si
vous voulez venir le protéger voilà je
vous ai tout dit vous savez tout à vous
de me dire ce que vous en pensez en bas
dans les commentaires et nous on se
retrouve très bientôt pour parler d'une
nouvelle iPad pro avec la puce m2 et ça
ça va être aussi extrêmement cool bisous
à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]